one touch of a button and the kebab
machine rolls into action Russian
intrapreneurs na slova mark shock is
impressed she thinks it could help cut
costs at her kebab chain in Moscow you
don't need a man it's getting and
another person is free to just to make a
quick sandwich and do you know and sell
its save time and money smart jock and
her husband are checking out the latest
innovations at this kebab trade fair in
Istanbul from lit up kebabs to infrared
grills the range is huge visitors from
over 30 countries can scope out the
latest technology the Turkish meat
sandwich is popular worldwide Giada
Hagen mistress me 500 million kebab
sandwiches are sold around the world
every day our industry provides more
than 2 million jobs if you include the
suppliers of meat and other ingredients
some vasilich make your dream as a
busser europe but in downtown is done
but we find some kebab sellers are
skeptical about the labor saving gizmos
well my guess here Buxton give them like
that's good if I use a knife to cut the
meat carefully the fat stays in the meat
which helps to keep the taste but if I
now take an electric knife all the fat
drips down as I cut you electric aids
kill the taste without condition back at
the trade fair few seem to share that
opinion the industry is growing in the
view here is it needs a helping hand you
know no [ __ ] with a nice little are
chucks husband says they're the first to
set up a kebab manufacturing company in
Russia and they intend to make it top
quality others rent a small patch of
land and set up shop on their own he
says but the quality is usually for in
the Russia
and if the business takes off the couple
plan to invest in their own kabob
machine like the ones they've seen here